this is a story about one of the most
audacious Financial frauds in history
a very complicated conspiracy involving
a 100 million dollar oil tanker
and also the murder of someone involved
we now know that David mokit had sort of
stumbled into one of the most lucrative
Maritime frauds in history
he was assassinated with a bomb that was
meant only for him
[Music]
this is the story of a single oil tanker
that was attacked and burned in what
everyone thought was a was a piracy
incident but turned out to be something
much darker and stranger
my assumption was that the days of
Pirates of the Caribbean or ancient
history and
um everything cleans up but the more we
dug into what happened to this one ship
the more criminality we found
this story really exposed just how
corrupt and Lawless frankly the global
shipping industry can be
foreign
[Music]
I'm a senior writer with Bloomberg and
with Matthew Campbell we are the authors
of dead in the water
the belante virtuoso was kind of a
Workhorse of international trade it was
like thousands of other oil tankers just
taking a million barrels of oil from one
port to another over and over again
several times a year
and the burlante was very large it was a
275 meter long vessel which believe it
or not is not does not put it among the
very very largest oil tankers and
container ships but but it's huge it's
almost three football fields
[Music]
and on this particular Journey it was
heading from Ukraine to China and had
just passed through the Suez Canal and
was sailing out into the Gulf of Aden
now the Gulf of Aden sits between Yemen
and the North and the Horn of Africa
Somalia in the south and at the time of
this Voyage summer of 2011. piracy was
at its absolute height there have been
two more pirate attacks off the coast of
Africa bringing the number to eight in
the past 12 days
well he used to go down several times a
week is that you know little fast-moving
boat carrying seven or eight guys with
AK-47s would come up alongside these
gigantic cargo ships carrying hundreds
of millions of dollars worth of cargo
and they would you know clamber their
way aboard take control of the vessel
and then take it back to Somalia and
demand millions of dollars in Ransom
any Sailors on board such a vessel would
have known that they were heading into
Waters where if pirates succeeded in
getting aboard they and their vessel
could be taken hostage and perhaps taken
to Somalia and held there for ransom for
months or or even years
which is why there was this extra
measure taken for security they decided
they needed a security a security detail
to go with them through the Gulf of Aden
it was nearly midnight and there was a
couple of sailors on Watch and both
Filipino guys and they spotted on the
radar a small craft approaching at first
they had no idea what it was or what was
going on and of course they were
terrified but when the when the the
small boat approached they used a
loudspeaker to shout down and uh they
the guys on the little vessel said we're
security with a security detail can you
can you lower your ladder so we can come
aboard
within seconds of them arriving on the
ship they started waving their rifles
around and commandeered the vessel and
it became clear very quickly this was a
terrible situation for all the crew who
were rounded up and locked in a TV room
um and then for the next couple of hours
they were sort of stuck in darkness just
listening and waiting
um you know dreading what might be
happening they were their worst fear was
that they'd be taken off to Somalia and
locked in some prison uh awaiting Ransom
payment to be paid so they were all you
know completely terrified
the ship started to move and then there
was a loud explosion and smoke started
pouring into the TV room where all the
crew were waiting and when they came out
they saw the these these armed men had
disappeared uh apparently fled and left
the belante virtuoso carrying a million
barrels of oil and burning
[Music]
so when a large commercial vessel is
destroyed or seriously damaged this
whole industry of of people swings into
action and that's because
a damaged commercial vessel that might
be carrying you know 100 200 300 million
dollars of cargo or more that might
itself be worth 100 million dollars or
more it is also above all a liability
that vessel is insured and that
insurance policy could be valued in the
many many many millions of dollars
so among the very first people who were
brought in when there is a big Marine
accident are what's called Maritime
surveyors and a maritime surveyor is
kind of like the person the insurance
company would send if if you had a tree
fall on your house the insurance company
needs to first of all make sure that a
tree actually did fall on your house
assess the damage
figure out if you you know perhaps push
the tree onto your house intentionally
write up a report and basically all
being well that report is favorable and
and then your claim is paid so a marine
surveyor essentially does that on
massive scale and in the case of the
burlante virtuoso there was a very good
marine surveyor a British guy who
happened to live in Yemen in Aden which
was the nearest city to where this
incident occurred
David mocker is this uh
this big Brash confident guy with a
booming laugh who lives is an expat life
in Yemen and he knows the area very well
he's been there for a long time
um and he's also you know an expert in
shipping he was once uh once a master
Mariner in the commercial Navy and he's
got Decades of experience doing this
work so you know it's it's a problem
it's difficult to try and get out to a
vessel 10 miles off the coast of Yemen
that's Ablaze but for someone like David
mocker it's something he's more than
capable of doing so he hitches a ride on
a fishing trawler to get out to the
brillante virtuoso
but he did have some initial trouble
getting on board the burlante it was a
bit slow to get permission and the the
way that works is that when there is a
marine accident typically a vessel then
becomes the the property of what's
called a salvage crew
and salvos are the 911 service of the
high seas when a vessel runs into
trouble comes to grief Salvage Crews
race to the scene to try and keep it
from sinking pull it off rocks whatever
needs to be done and from that point on
the ship is the responsibility of
Salvage Crews who who ultimately work
for the ship's owners
I think David mockett would have known
pretty early on that there was something
suspicious about what happened to the
Volante virtuoso
[Music]
one of the things he noticed was there
was no evidence of a rocket-propelled
grenade strike supposedly an RPG had
started the fire David saw no evidence
of this
he was confused by the fact that the
pirate attack had occurred in the middle
of the night which is not typically how
Somali pirates operate they would
usually strike in daylight
he didn't notice any evidence of weapons
being discharged of bullet holes or
anything like that which again was was
part of the story
so he didn't have any positive theory of
what had occurred he just had certain
suspicions that there was more to it
than the initial accounts suggested
and when he arrived and spoke to the
Salvage crew the attitude was kind of
strange they had they sat down and had
dinner one evening and the salvas were
quizzing David mucket about what he was
doing in a place like like Yemen and the
Greek Salvage Captain said to him you
should be at home with your
grandchildren you shouldn't be in a
place like this
[Music]
David mockett went back to his office in
Aden and started the process of sending
his reports back to London so the
insurers could get a clear idea of what
happened and in those early reports you
can see that he's suspicious about the
whole thing and indeed he you know he
tells his employers
um I need to go and find out what's
happened he's going to go and talk to
his local government contacts he's going
to dig a bit deeper and try and find out
the true story but he never gets a
chance to do that
[Music]
so on July 20th 2011 about two weeks
after the attack and fire that that all
but destroyed the burlante virtuoso
David was working in his office in Ayden
as usual
he typically got to work very early in
the morning you know between seven and
eight he would work until lunchtime that
he would go home have lunch at home stay
home for a few hours and and then return
to work later in the day
and a totally normal morning he drove to
his office parked
and when it came time to go home for
lunch he got up walked out the hall
climbed into his Lexus SUV
and turned the key drove out of the car
park of this small office building where
he had his his workspace
and then on to a very busy road one of
the main roads of Aden actually and he
hadn't gone more than a couple hundred
meters when a bomb that had been placed
under the driver's seat detonated
killing him instantly
[Music]
there wasn't a big explosion it was a
very targeted incident
um in a way that really you know people
afterwards could only explain as being
an assassination whoever placed that
bomb wanted to kill David market
so the British government did take some
action as it does when when a Britain is
killed abroad
the foreign office did try and ascertain
the circumstances of what had occurred
ultimately the Met police sent an
investigator to Aiden to liaise with the
yemeni police
but really there was not much the
British government could do Yemen at
this time was incredibly dangerous there
were no British diplomats in Aden
whatsoever there was no British Presence
at all
you know off the death of David mockett
there was a there was an inquest into
his death and um the coroner found that
he'd been unlawfully killed but didn't
know who had done it there was no
evidence as to who had killed him but
there was evidence that that inquest
that he'd been he'd been targeted
because he was on the verge of
uncovering a criminal conspiracy but
after that finding you know there was no
police action there was no full
investigation it was all just sort of
forgotten about the only thing that was
left was an insurance dispute
foreign
[Music]
a large vessel like the burlante
virtuoso is destroyed or or effectively
destroyed in this case
insurance companies specifically
insurers who operate through the Lloyds
of London Insurance Market are on the
hook for a great deal of money perhaps
hundreds of millions of dollars in this
case The Vessel itself What's called the
hull insurance was worth about 80
million US Dollars there was also a
hundred million dollars in cargo
Insurance because the the oil on board
was insured separately from The Vessel
itself so this is a very large liability
even for big insurance companies even at
Lloyd's which is the world's most
important insurance Market where they
deal in huge transactions
and of course if you're on the hook for
that much money you generally would not
want to pay it out unless you're you're
very confident that the claim is
legitimate in practice they might settle
you know maybe pay you 50 percent or or
maybe uh come to some other amicable
Arrangement what they're very unlikely
to do is to go to court to try and fight
you about it however in the case that
belong to virtuoso these London insurers
looking at this huge bill with which
they were faced and looking at the
circumstances of what had occurred and
also taking into account the death of
David Market who was one of their own a
creature of the Lloyd's world and of the
maritime World they decided to fight and
to go nose to nose in court
and this insurance dispute had become
you know overtly hostile
um
the Greek ship owner was a guy called
Marius iliopolis and they decided they
weren't going to pay his claim on the
basis that they didn't believe it was a
genuine Act of piracy and so it sets the
scene for you know this high-stakes
London lawsuit which turns out to be the
best chance we're going to get to really
understand what happened here
[Music]
the owner specifically was a man named
Marios iliopolis who was a prominent
Greek shipping Tycoon
owned a fleet of oil tankers also the
owner of something called sea Jets which
is one of the most popular fast Ferry
services linking Athens to places like
Mykonos and Santorini
and uh
one of the fun things to know about
Mario ciliopolis is he has a hobby
he's a rally driver and a very
successful rally driver he's known in
the rally world as Super Mario he tends
to do quite well in rally races
[Music]
really a a Pursuit that requires nerves
of Steel and a certain disregard for
risk which would probably come in handy
in the shipping business
even years after the event no one had
got a satisfactory story out of the
captain or the chief engineer of the
ship no one had sat down and interviewed
the Salvage crew any evidence of what
happened to the ship had been destroyed
the ship was was sent off to a scrap
yard and Torn to Pieces so the insurers
had an enormous Challenge on their hands
to prove that this was an act of fraud
rather than an act of piracy
when you're seeking to invalidate in
court an 80 million dollar insurance
claim or nearly 80 million dollar
insurance claim you need a huge amount
of evidence and one of the things you do
is you hire private investigators and
there is a small universe
of these guys typically ex-police who do
a lot of insurance cases so in this case
there were two private investigators who
were hired named Richard veal and
Michael Connor
and they were digging deeper and deeper
into what happened to the ship and what
happened to David mockets and they were
doing you know the work that should have
been done in the media aftermath of the
attack which is find the sailors find
the maritime officials find the
witnesses to what happened and talk to
them and get their stories
one of the whistleblowers who came
forward to tell the truth about the
fraud on the balante virtuoso was
working with the Salvage crew and
arrived at the scene shortly after the
attack and was there as the Salvage crew
ensured that the fire didn't go out that
the ship was completely destroyed and
that the insurance fraud had a better
chance of success but because he was
based in Yemen and because he knew the
ship owner and because he knew the the
Salvage Captain had known them for
several months he witnessed all these
events happening he witnessed the
planning he knew that a vessel was going
to come to yemeni Waters and be attacked
and destroyed in an insurance fraud he
had absolutely Vital Information for the
police and for the insurance
investigators but he put his life at
risk by by revealing it
he had a life in Greece and he had to
flee in Terror you know he had to get
taken taken away by armed guards and put
on a plane to the UK and
you know when he gave evidence in court
the Greek whistleblower was flanked by
police officers from an unknown location
like he's still living and hiding
[Music]
they also were able to interview a
member of the crew who admitted later on
that he had
faked his story because he'd been
threatened by Mario ciliopolis so
piecing all this evidence together they
were able to assemble a body of evidence
that that they felt was strong enough to
really fight this case
the judge takes a few weeks to hand down
his decision but when he does you know
it's a damning indictment of the ship
owner he says that Mario silopoulos is a
dishonest witness that he disgracefully
threatened members of the courts uh and
that he's not telling the truth about
um you know what happened to the ship
and what happened in the lawsuits and
his misconduct is so serious that this
claim is thrown out
a prosecution of David Market's Murder
By the UK was always going to be a very
long shot this crime the murder occurred
in a far away land where Britain has no
presence obviously no jurisdiction so so
expecting a British prosecution for for
that act I think was always going to be
a long shot what I am much more
surprised by is that no British law
enforcement agency has seriously pursued
a prosecution uh in the what what a
London judge has now ruled was a fraud
one of the reasons that the police
struggled to get to grips with what
happened in Maritime fraud is that it
takes place in the cracks between the
traditional areas of law enforcement
um in this case you had a Greek owned
ship carrying oil that was being traded
out of Cyprus to China
crewed by Filipino sailors
flying the flag of Liberia in West
Africa so you've got seven or eight
different nation states already involved
and the question is who prosecutes this
crime whose job it is to deal with this
and the reality of law enforcement is
that actually no one wants the job it's
incredibly difficult to uh to
investigate and prosecute any fraud that
happens out at sea
and so most
police forces around the world just
decide that it's not for them to do and
they can't do it and with in the case
The brillante Virtue where so the police
were interested they were given evidence
that something underwater had happened
and they decided it was going to be too
difficult to prosecute a case
no one has ever been prosecuted no one
has ever been charged for a very
significant fraud that was attempted
against the Lloyd's Market one of
Britain's most important financial
institutions
David mocker had spent a lifetime either
working at sea or in far-flung ports
around the world and you know he was
looking forward to spending finally
spending some time with his wife and his
daughters and their grandchildren who
loved him
and you know the tragedy of the
brillante virtuoso is that he was killed
before he had a chance to do that
iliopolis did actually uh do okay
financially out of this believe it or
not uh one of the things that happened
was that the bank which had loaned the
money to illiopolis to buy the burlante
virtuoso wrote off the debt in the
course of this litigation concluding
that it would never be recovered so from
the debt side he was free and clear by
destroying the vessel with a fire he was
able to you know Escape debts of in the
region of 60 70 million dollars and the
ship was losing losing enormous amount
of money and was coming towards the end
of its life so from a from a purely
Financial point of view destroying the
burlante virtuos so it was the best
thing he could have done
part of me is expected people in the
shipping world to come out and say
it's not that bad you know it's not as
bad as this one ship makes it appear to
be but no one's done that and you know
unfortunately I think there is this
underbelly to to global Shipping that is
thriving and there seems to be very
little that anyone can do about it the
more you dig the worse it seems to look